how's it goin resume its back welcome to
the final episode of speedrunners who's
gonna win no one unless you watch the
video then you would know other sticks
oh good
they will under state now PewDiePie has
done it everyone well we want to do it I
don't even know what we're talking about
anymore top resist oh I dare you stop
don't anyone wanna rock it in their foot
how do stick your rocket in the butt
come at me you're welcome hey don't you
dare grapple me
don't you dare grapple me I know you
want to minx I know you want that's okay
she doesn't want to find don't grapple
me nice I have no desire to grapple
anyone why would I do like rocket in
this no don't hassle me oh that is good
that is some good grappling Sun that's
better for me I think yes get back for
sure
all this checking it back you babe I'm
time oh [ __ ] we both have grapples we
both have grapples you know you have to
do an app needs right now yep run away
from Ken that little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how'd it feel like I lost my virginity
baby what happened gave me back and
check it away from me I didn't know you
had one
did you just get it oh come on that just
genuinely heard my feel oh oh somebody
somebody told me you're gonna get
grappled oh [ __ ] please don't please so
it was a mistake I have a grapple you
grapple me I grapple you hey that's what
I call something catchy okay [ __ ] calm
something catchy it's your next beam
sexy and you think you can say at every
video think about it like my health my
bowels anymore hey I do sometimes how
they I did in their moment is right I'll
do it what are you doing here hey Dad
hey Oh said that I could genuinely hurt
my voice
damn get him get him get him get him get
him do you have a grapple - don't think
I know what your scheme is that means
grappling moment waiting for double
grapple sucker grapple in your dick
[ __ ] don't you dare grapple me don't
you how does y'all's go through the wall
I'm on won't its you got a gravel in the
right moment [ __ ] whatever I grappled
before you were born [ __ ] grappled your
mom rocket oh hell no you did not just
say that not just say that next time you
meet my mom I will tell her you said
that
yeah next time I come I'll tell her oh
my god there's a cyclize how dare you
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you you little
[ __ ] do you think this is a game
I cut you you're gonna cut me I'm gonna
have a cube man I'm gonna cut off pieces
didn't even know you had it's inside so
you little [ __ ]
I don't [ __ ] tryharding like go ahead
okay truce this craphole hair okay thank
you grapple my mom just came back to
soften the blow Super Saiyan Jen super
saying ken is that it funny anymore
[ __ ] Ken man [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] him add the base you're the
shittiest piece of [ __ ] that's bro ha
god I hate you oh god I hate you Ken god
I hate you don't something isn't good
[ __ ] you don't I'm who to say to [ __ ]
suck that one you little [ __ ] see yours
went through everything is stained and I
will not pick you up I was your CI state
well you're on my pain pain oh yeah I
said it why don't you just die like the
little cockroach [ __ ] ass nugget owe me
a car effect
oh hey tell me how you feel so calm
believe you want again peds you failed
so that
I love this game that's game ever oh
anything anymore
Chardin I am failing why do I go
backwards why do I go backward go minx
for the love of God go I will try my
best feuds Emily you do anyway and he
doesn't work so try harder okay I'm
thinking about the world jump I'm
prepping myself for the wall jump
okay just let it slide like in real life
and double jump there what the hell was
that
hello voice act come on boxes you could
call that a box like come on he's gonna
get the speed now you gotta drop the
boxes so you can get better items oh god
damn it just get get a grapple and
grapple it grapple him oh yes that's
what I'm talking about that's what I'm
talking about
ping I'm complaining more than anyone
and I'm the one losing does it why is it
you two against me huh because you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] and everyone hates you I'm
not [ __ ] up you don't know oh oh oh
gonna replay that once everyone sees it
twice let's back into it no need a minor
in your deck I'm dead so badly
Oh God god I hate you god I hate good I
don't need I don't need anybody's help
to win this come on let's you better win
flawless [ __ ]
I'm flawless I'm flawless I'm flawless
how are you catching up on me I'm doing
it perfectly is for you
oh [ __ ] you all [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you oh
you sly up in real life grab that [ __ ]
give me the speed
give me the mine explode in your how is
that even [ __ ] oh my god this is my
god is canceled you just met me grandpa
that [ __ ] sucker in his ass gonna
grapple like I can never travel before
why don't you dodge al meriya bhai he's
losing you pH shutter half I know
exactly what I'm doing
you once did it which I did I know what
I'm doing why a facile ma doesn't even
make any [ __ ] sense
[Laughter]
that's the best game ever gasps I'll
have this game I love it too now that I
can see the ground is so easy
mr. wrong Felix like himself and what
[Laughter]
good god I hate you so much I hope you
like it was never read in the newspaper
tomorrow that you die intense painful
death I be okay you know what [ __ ] that
guy it wasn't angry anyway that's how we
do it
I needed ice I think you guys are losing
on purpose just because you're scared of
what's gonna happen
like never love or the food can't forget
go half the time we can't take your
intensity pedes what's [ __ ] Miami that
jump going wrong where you dick violent
yes you are
I can't figure out oh yeah get to speed
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I was a crazy now
I am so angry right now lucky one
there's no intensity I can't even take
pride of that [ __ ] alright that's all
for speedrunners for now hope you
enjoyed this miniseries I know it got a
little bug hurt but that's life isn't it
not really yeah yeah it is maybe like if
you're always watching hit subscribe
home birth today I see you bros in next
video yeah middle Tommy no I don't don't
you power bond up you [ __ ] guys
bam bam Shazam Sam and it's ma'am yet